deedy I want to start with you because
this is a film that you and Jeremy
kleiner your production company partner
have been seeing through for as I
understand it a decade 10 years what
made you decide to take these two books
these two memoirs one by David Sheff one
by Nick chef and make them into a film
and what has it been like for you I'm
sure it felt virgin and timely and
relevant ten years ago but even more so
I would imagine over the last decade
well to the last part of your question
yes regrettably I think you just don't
know what's happening in the universe
but I do think it participates I do
think it's part of the equation and I
don't I don't think any of us had any
idea that when the movie would hit the
world it would be when this is so sadly
in the headlines every day but I but
I've done this long enough to do that I
do believe movies they sort of they are
talking back to you and they are telling
you when they're ready to come out and
when their moment is so that is sadly
just true Jeremy kleiner who's here and
my partner in crime and nearly in life
we we read both these books ten years
ago and what we we were moved by both of
them very much but I think we were also
additionally moved by the fact that they
both existed and that there was an
opportunity to tell a story about a
family about fracture about shame about
love that was committed to two sides of
the story we didn't think that had ever
been done and we knew it was going to be
a high-wire act that probably broke a
lot of rules about traditional
screenplay writing and three act
structure and active protagonists and
all that stuff but we knew the stories
were profound and and dimensional and
kaleidoscopic and from the heart and so
we thought let's try and then
fortunately we got to hand it over to
this group Felix for you this is your
first english-language feature as I
mentioned
you had the broken circle breakdown
which was nominated for Best Foreign
Language Academy Award a few years ago
see it if you haven't thank you what
made you decide this was the best
project for your first English language
feature a couple of things these guys
who had been making great great films
and pitched his story and then really
connecting to it on so many levels so
red board books I met David and Nick
they had seen my film I felt that there
was a lot of trust from them in me
tackling this story taking on this story
and you know I just felt a huge
connection to the family to what they go
through as many people I think I - and
my family have experienced or we know
people that have experienced it from
afar and from clothes so I I could
relate to it on that level
- and and it was just an eye-opener for
me in in seeing this this beautiful
family who believes in an unconditional
love who never stops fighting so yeah it
does go to dark places because it's
authentic and real and raw and that is
partly why I wanted to do it but maybe
mostly because it's it's it's such a
beautiful family
Steve I can imagine how exciting it must
have been for you to have David Sheff
available to you to get to know him but
I also would imagine it's like cooking a
steak you don't want to undercook it and
not get to know him enough you don't
want to overcook it and almost spend too
much time with him how did you figure
out what the good middle ground would be
for getting to know him the right amount
first of all may I use that analogy
going forward okay I like whenever
anyone asks me about this film I'll say
it was like cooking a steak but then I
won't to explain the analogy yeah
there's a built in you know it's tough
it's because he's a real guy
and I think there's a responsibility
built into that but there's it's also
weird when you meet somebody that you
are going to portray you don't want them
to feel like they are your science
project because that's just creepy and
we we went and we had lunch and and it
wasn't about that it wasn't about oh how
is he eating his soup you know I'm gonna
do that and he didn't want it that way
either he just was very forthcoming and
very generous with his time and more
than anything I just got a sense for the
kind of man he is and which is very
generous and open and kind and loving
and you know all of the things that he
writes about in the book and so I just
wanted to feel who he was and it was
exactly what I imagined him to be
Timothy similar question for you
I haven't read the memoirs but I will
assume that the notebook that we see
Steve page into her must be based in
reality that's something that Nick did
were you able to see any of his writings
and drawings that were outside of the
memoir did you glean things from that or
from talking to him what was most
helpful to you well I think like Steve
said well actually quickly about that
journal Jasper in the movie the real
Jasper in real life he was a PA on our
movie and he did all the drawings and
those journals so there weren't Nick's
drawings but they were told is he now
he's 63 years now he's like 24 or
something yeah and and I think Steve
said it that was like so perfect and
that doesn't yes yes but like you know
you you don't want to like creep them
out in any way didn't feel like it was a
biopic and it's also kind of was like
the lens of the role I felt like just
find the humanity and the guy don't try
and play a drug addict in any way that
felt like naive or self-serving or
something so uh I think the biggest gift
I got from Nick and that I've heard
Steve say similar thing about David is
was kind of like license to go and like
like go make this thing and and and
without a like a stringent Nisour
something like that Amy you and I had a
conversation before I saw the film and I
had seen the trailer and realized that a
lot of your stuff was on the telephone
so I was very excited when I saw the
movie and realized that you actually
have a couple scenes or at least one
scene you know with with Steve which was
really cool do you feel like because we
talked about how to make the phone
scenes feel authentic and in many cases
you've you know the other one was
actually on the phone whenever it could
be done that way right yeah that was
extremely helpful Steve was crouched
behind the couch for me and I was same
for him even when we weren't doing the
scene communicate with each other it's
where we feel safest but there was a day
remember because the the cell phone I
was using when I'm at my office is you
know a relic from only five years ago
it's a period film so but Steve on his
day off graciously was like I'll call in
and I'll be on the other side and the
phone couldn't support that
but our ad our wonderful ad not the same
so like having having that company and
and such a supportive group and
supportive you know all around from crew
to cast and filmmakers that everyone was
just had each other's back and you felt
that more of the film is is lyrical its
episodic in a way it is jumping back
within seconds two different time
periods were you as an actor cognizant
more of where each moment fit in the
chronological story of these characters
lives or were you more cognizant of
where it fit in the story of the script
or it was the former
I'm not smart enough maybe to do the
letter I don't know but it um I also had
spoken to Karen on the phone a few times
and she was also very forthcoming and
very frank and very open and honest and
funny but I heard the story from her so
that's I which I took a lot of notes
from those discussions so that's kind of
the timeline I went by I would ask her
questions about scenes in the script and
she would fill in the details so that's
that's the order I want is her memory
essentially was most helpful to me Felix
indeed it can you explain to me along
how you guys came up with this the
manner of telling it in the way you do
with the jumps was that something that
was your vision was at Luke Davies a
screenwriter how did that all come about
it's a long process and it started
writing the script that Indiana with it
we did refine it we we took it one step
further we drew out scenes that weren't
that were just expository as it goes and
and took it to a boulder level I would
say but it was always it was always the
intention to use the flashbacks of
course and and the journey while
developing the script and writing
different drafts was how do they how do
they fit in how do how how does it help
the flow of the movie but how do you
really create the experience of somebody
going through this so yeah and it works
the way memory works for for David for
Steve's character it is really putting
the pieces together as he's going
through it as he's realizing that he is
losing his son he remembers the good
moments he also questions himself like
you know should I have done this where
did I go wrong should have a scene signs
so all of that was a set it was part of
the script writing but it got it got we
took it one step further and in the Edit
well I think you all for opening all of
our eyes and thank you for being here
today it's great to see all of you